on part à présent la chasse aux fausses
informations avec antoine photo
so un fox fox non pas pour renard mais
un fox fausses informations avec vous
mais c'est merveilleux
et au menu de ce soir un événement
dramatique c'est la fusillade au texas à
l'origine d'un fox transphobes vous
voyez absolument raphaël peu après ces
tueries on le rappelle qui a fait 21
morts dont 19 enfants dans une école du
texas certains ont cru pouvoir faire
correspondre leurs visions de l'idée de
la réalité avec l'identité du tueur tout
part de cette photo que vous apercevez
relayé par ce compte twitter il affirme
que la personne que l'on voit donc sur
cette photo est l'auteur de la fusillade
il s'agit d'une personne en jupe les
abreuver semblablement un homme avec un
drapeau d'ailleurs lui l'utilisateur lui
ne fait pas d'allusion transphobes il
dit juste et bien il a tué 24 personnes
dont 19 étaient des enfants certains
revanche aux états unis rafale et c'est
plus inquiétant ont sauté sur l'occasion
voir leurs rides et transphobes s'aligne
avec la réalité et notamment c'est assez
grave et bien un sénateur républicain
sont des représentants républicains
pardonnez-moi son tweet a été supprimé
mais vous l'apercevez ici repris par un
autre internaute il dit le tireur est un
étranger illégal de gauche transsexuel
le trc dans l'ordre si vous me permettez
l'expression
cependant il y a un problème il se
trouve que c'est faux la rumeur elle
elle trouve son origine sur cette page
vous l'apercevez là encore il s'agit
d'une capture d'une archive et car elle
a été également supprimés c'est un
espace de discussion sur forchana un
forum apprécié par l'extrême droite
la discussion est aujourd'hui supprimé
on voit ce que disait un de ses
utilisateurs ici juste là il disait
salvador ramos le tireur est
probablement un transsexuel rumeurs qui
va ensuite s'exporter sur reddit un
autre forum bien bien connus ou la
personne font qu'on a vu en photo et
bien possède un compte cette fois son
compte et bien le voici qu'ils postent
les postent des photos de sa vie de
personnes transgenres et notamment des
photos en jute comme celle ci que vous
apercevez dans cette biographie elle se
présente comme tron genre et lesbiennes
artiste est énorme nerd également des
photos utilisé par certains
sympathisants d'extrême droite pour
justifier leurs croyances transphobes à
travers une vague ressemblance la rumeur
a tellement enflé raphaël enfin que
cette utilisatrice a dû se défendre
toujours sur edit moins de deux heures
après la tuilerie elle a posté cette
photo on y voit donc le fameux drapeau
vous avez aperçu dans la première photo
avec ce commentaire ce n'est pas moi je
ne vis même pas au texas malheureusement
antoine ce démenti n'a pas suffi la
publication est devenue virale elle a
même traversé l'atlantique oui
absolument et la fachosphère français
sondés délecter en de cette publication
a commencé par andré bercoff le
journaliste verser dans la mouvance
identitaire voire complotistes qu'il a
partagé cette photo avec ce commentaire
où il le savoure la fin d'un empire
décomposer le déclin de la pelle empire
américain en quelque sorte vous l'avez
compris un autre utilisateur lui qui se
présente cette fois comme un catholique
ancien militaire il voit un ravage de
l'idéologie hook malgré le démenti il
n'est pas revenu sur cette pro sur ces
propos le tireur lui et bien le voici
une vague ressemblance avec la personne
trojan en tout cas après avoir dit tu es
19 enfants le tireur lui a laissé dans
son sillage une nouvelle victime la
minorité tranchant et surtout la vérité
voilà pour sa part phoque sordide autre
aveugle on voulait nous parler c'est en
ukraine cette fois oui une fois n'est
pas coutume à fox autour de cette photo
raphaël vous la voyez elle a été
partagée par ceux conquis la femme ce
sont des soldats ukrainien qui brûlent
un drapeau néerlandais en le confondant
avec celui de la russie en cause bien
sûr le faible niveau d'éducation des
ukrainiens c'est ce qu'affirme en tout
cas cet internaute pourtant eh bien
c'est faux pour s'en apercevoir il
suffit d'une simple recherche d'image
inversée ce n'est pas du tout ça une
simple recherche d'image inversé on
tombe sur la vidéo que vous voyez ici en
photo que je n'ai pas pu vous montrer
malheureusement cette vidéo date de 2016
donc on y voit ses hommes cagoulés et
armés de vendre un pot de l'ukraine qui
tiennent un discours
affirmant à être du bataillon azoff et
menacé les pays bas de représailles ça
on va y revenir mais sur la publication
en elle-même d'abord plusieurs choses
doivent vous alerter d'abord
l'utilisateur lui il se définit fille
comme patriote mais il n'a posté qu'une
seule vidéo et ensuite il renvoie vers
un lien soit disantes de la vidéo
originale du bataillon azoff pourtant et
bien cette vidéo elle est introuvable ça
ressemble à une un fox pensée préparés
et diffusés pour nuire précisément
bataille oui absolument et le groupe de
combattants a démenti sur stop fake ce
site que je vous propose ici un instant
médias ukrainiens il
il affirmé bien ne pas être à l'origine
de cette vidéo qu'ils présentent eux
comme une tentative de déstabilisation
le bataillon azoff qui sur sa chaîne
officielle cette fois lui propose ce
n'est toujours pas ça décidément la
tablette me joue des tours aujourd'hui
mon cher raphaël qui propose croyez moi
sur parole d'une vidéo et bien où ils le
dénoncent et il le montre que c'est très
facile de se faire passer pour eux il
montre donc comment il est possible en
mettant simplement une simple kaboul en
posant avec une arme et un drapeau de
dire qu'il s'agit du bataillon oiseaux
sur le fond en revanche la fausse vidéo
al elle dénonce la signature d'un accord
entre le pays bas et l'ukraine s'étaient
en 2016 un texte qui prévoyait un accord
d'association entre l'union européenne
et l'ukraine à l'époque conclusion une
fausse vidéo probablement croyez moi sur
parole musharraf à elle réalisé par des
trolls pro-russe pour nuire donc au
bataillon azoff et plus largement à
l'ukraine merci antoine fenaux c'était
info ou intox présenté par antoine on se
retrouve dans quatre minutes un peu
moins maintenant pour un nouveau journal
dans paris direct
[Musique]